into the spider-verse is one of my
favorite comic book films ever made it
made huge leaps in bringing a more
artistic appeal to CG animation and it
perfectly captured the essence of what a
comic book feels like to read I would
love to see more stories told in this
world but the problem is it took years
of research and development to innovate
the style of the film it took so long in
fact that at the end of the process the
creative team behind the film started to
implement machine learning into their
workflow and since the film's release in
2018 it will be four years until we get
the sequel so in the meantime the
question I'm asking is is it possible to
replicate the style of the film in a
procedural manner we've been
experimenting with a lot of AI tools
here at the studio in particular AI
image generation last week I had a huge
breakthrough with a program called
stable diffusion and I think this method
will allow us to tell a story in the
spider-verse universe by letting us take
a real piece of footage
and taking it into the spider-verse
Dean you have something you have
something cool to show me right I'm not
looking to have something I want you to
spoil it we put out a video called the
death of the effects you broke new
ground with AI image generation I found
some new ground and I'm going to break
that ground now in front of you here is
my first test
wow looks like you're an Arcane like
this stuff usually looks like garbage
and yours doesn't look like garbage okay
I'll show you a little more this is me
in the in the popular film Man of Steel
that looks really good that's like deep
fake level quality I call it the stable
fake the stable thing the closest we got
to like an animation run through stable
diffusion that looked anywhere decent
was like the low polygon Jurassic Park
test but even then it's like we're all
over the place just every once in a
while there's a glimpse like oh that
almost worked but if you could fix that
you basically make it so people can make
animations without having to actually
hand draw every frame they can just take
video and you appear to have fixed it
how are you doing this we're applying a
process that you have used previously
when you were running those deep fake
the program you were using deep face lab
would kick out these stabilized face
sets yeah yeah I applied that process
here did a track of the face punched in
on that exported that and then ran that
through stable infusion what that does
is it really just allows a consistent
character to emerge by using a locked
seed here Nico what does that mean
how did how does stable diffusion how do
diffusion models work in the simplest of
terms it's a noise pattern that the
computer looks at and tries to interpret
an image from it's basically the
electronic equivalent of looking at
clouds and trying to see what they look
like it's like oh it's kind of a face
with a hat that kind of looks like an
alligator what you're doing here is
you're basically telling stable
diffusion like take this noise pattern
and interpret it as deem
from Arcane and because a picture of you
with a noise put on top you can already
have your likeness but it has some
flexibility to kind of put that style on
there the problem is stable diffusion on
each frame usually changes the noise you
have a blotch here that gets viewed as
Shadow but the next frame now all the
blotches are in different spots so maybe
the hair is a little bit different and
there's a shadow over here and the eye
got adjusted weird but what you're doing
is you're locking the noise so it's the
same noise pattern in every frame the
problem with that is when things move
under that noise pattern you're going to
see everything kind of like stick to the
spots and it's like you pause on one
frame and it looks really good but I'm
wearing a wrist watch and this one frame
and then the next frame I'm not but
you're solving that problem by locking
everything to the face and having the
face just locked in the middle of the
frame so the noise stays locked on top
so I'm able to achieve this art style
thanks to a guy named Nitro stock on
this website called hugging face he's
created these different stable diffusion
models that have specific training on
different art styles and he's also
created a model for into the
spider-verse and you can apply the same
process as a matter of fact
I took a scene from Spider-Man 2
and applied the into the spider-verse
really model
I drove Spider-Man away
he was the only one who could have
stopped Octavius
yes well is the result wow so that's Jay
Jonah into the spider-verse
wow the face is the most important thing
and in the face the eyes are the most
important thing I can see where he's
looking and I can see what he's thinking
I really want to take this process we're
seeing here because this Jay Jones
Jameson shot is my favorite I would love
to see this style applied to maybe the
MCU wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait spider-verse took four years
to make and thousands and thousands of
artists you have the arrogance to think
that you can just one man with one
computer make any shot of spider verse
shot well I might need one other man
with one other computer and that guy
that that guy's name is better I think
with the help of Fenner we could maybe
take a look at the style of the
spider-verse films and try to replicate
that in Nuke Not only would we have
procedurally generated faces from stable
diffusion we would have a procedurally
generated look from those films I I have
one challenge for you can you give me
some new spider spider verse shots that
aren't just other frames the filter like
can you show me that you can truly
create spider-verse on your own using
this technique any excuse to put on a
Spider-Man costume
is a worthy one to me I will make
my spider verse fan film
[Music]
all right Fender we have decided to move
forward putting the MCU into the
spider-verse we're gonna pull up the
movie and we're going to dissect it
frame by frame and figure out how can we
build a system that procedurally
replicates that look so that we can plug
a shot in and it'll already look like
it's coming out of the spider verse
sweet I love it let's do it all right
let's do this one last time the first
thing I'm seeing here anything that has
exponential glow has that comic book
kind of halftone pattern the transition
from dark to light always has that
halftone pattern you'll see in the
Shadows on Spider-Man's face you see the
cross hatching that's not a crazy effect
for us to do like you just have
basically a simple Luma here we can have
the highlights reveal a half tone
pattern Shadow areas that can reveal our
crosshatch pattern there's another post
effect here that I think is critical to
achieving the look you guys can see in
the Deep background the colors begin to
separate and break apart and that's
chromatic aberration without using depth
of field this allowed them to to create
a separation between the subject and the
background and also this is the sort of
stuff we should be adding in like the
spidey sense squiggle lines and stuff
yeah and here like motion blur is it's
almost kind of like a ghosting stepping
yeah so that's something to pay
attention to as well a lot of times in
the movie The foreground character will
be on twos so they'll move every other
frame but the background is on once and
it'll move every frame anytime we have a
character on an abstract background we
should totally do twos the biggest thing
about this film's aesthetic they
embraced imperfections they brought
imperfections back into CG which is so
perfect whether that's the offset lines
you see on a character's Iris or sudden
pop frames that are from a completely
different art style all of these things
lend themselves to AI generated imagery
well I feel like we kind of have it
highlights are going to reveal our
halftone patterns Shadows are going to
reveal crosshatch pattern chromatic
aberration chromatic aberration for
separating out backgrounds from
foreground and then also paying
attention to those style frames just
like maybe we won't run like three
frames through stable diffusion just
lean heavy into the Jack Kirby art style
lean heavy into like an anime art style
like I think what we need to do is test
this process on a shot from no way home
to see if it's actually possible to
bring a real Spider-Man into the
spider-verse
thanks to today's sponsor established
titles Sam and Nico are now actual Lords
of Scotland how were they bestowed with
this with this honor due to established
titles man I think Lord Nico paringer
and Lord Sam Gorski deserve their own
Lord portraits let's generate some
portraits of them and then present it to
them with their established titles
established titles is a fun and novel
way to preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland while helping Global
reforestation efforts it is a Project
based on a historic Scottish custom
where landowners are referred to as
layers or Lords and Ladies in English oh
there he is Lord Nico paringer according
to this Proclamation Sam and Nico both
own one square foot of lordship in
edelston Scotland established titles
works with Charities one tree planted
and trees for the future to support
Global reforestation efforts and for
each title purchase that equals one tree
planted around the world what a worthy
cause there he is dude he has a ruby
earring I'm so jealous that Sam on his
credit cards on his plane tickets even
on his dating profiles we'll be able to
put the title of Lord Sam's married I
mean as a lord so we've got our
portraits ready and if you guys want to
join the corridor Kingdom the first 200
people to use our link will get a plot
within walking distance of our land and
together we can probably grow a giant
Corridor Kingdom and maybe take over
Scotland
[Music]
the Lords Sam and Nico your lordly
portrait what oh I look like an evil
Lord the first order of my court I need
to build battlements wait so am I like
your servant now yeah technically we all
are because you granted me like look at
what you did yeah you guys allies or
enemies though time will tell Nico I
know it can get lonely as a Lord but
luckily there's a Black Friday sale if
you go to establish titles and use the
code Corridor crew you can get 10 off
they have five foot plots
you got me a one by one well I think we
gotta leave now bye my lords just one
more time guys it's established
titles.com Corridor crew to get 10 off I
should get my own plot of land maybe
like a five by five I'd be their boss
I'd be there Lord
think about that
all right guys we have our first spider
verse test ready to watch all right
three two one go
[Music]
wow it looks like he's in the spider
verse
assistant yeah Fenner just did like a
little bit of Magic on it this looks
perfect it looks like something that a
professional Animation Studio created
for process spider-verse
so with this Andrew Garfield test
working I think we have our look dialed
in and we're ready to start diving into
this spider-verse short we're going to
write and edit a little piece using
footage from the MCU films and into the
spider-verse and Fender is going to take
a bunch of those shots and run him
through his nuke script thus applying
the spider-verse look to these MCU shots
in the meantime we have a few original
scenes that we need to film so I'm going
to squeeze into our dumbest Spider-Man
suit and hop in front of the green
screen and with the help of Matt I'm
going to shoot some plates that are
basically just going to end up as
reference for stable diffusion we'll run
my face independently through stable
diffusion to get me looking like a
spider-verse Tom Holland and then we'll
isolate the pajama suit in stable
diffusion and really push it to look
like the suit from Spider-Man homecoming
all we need is one usable frame and then
we can use this program called EB synth
to do a style transfer of that image
back onto the original plate and when
Fenner combines the face with the suit
and his nuke magic it'll look like an
animated shot of Tom Holland in the
spider-verse I just it's like I don't
know what I mean it looks great I have
no idea what I'm looking at I can't tell
if you're just playing these clips from
the spider-verse movie or not no this is
this is what I wanted to show you so you
saw me yesterday I was like Sam's gonna
think this is super lame but you add
spider once you add the cool filter you
become the real Spiderman whoa what and
so then you're running through EB synth
two so the costume is through EB send
and the face is through stable Fusion so
that was so crazy
at the other day I was just in stupid
pajamas if you guys want like a free
Oscar
do something original with this
I think that's the next
hey Nico you know so we're having a
freaking blast and we're getting some
really cool results I have like a few
reservations I feel like there's an
element of this where
I just hit generate on this button and
just get this sweet face out that looks
just like this film I love I kind of I
kind of questioned myself I'm like are
we just
stealing from these artists that we
super respect I don't know you've been
messing with the stuff longer than
anyone here and I just wonder like what
your perspective is on that I mean it
just comes down to like being open about
things right like you guys didn't make
the spiderverse style if you made like a
short film and you just use the
spider-verse style and you didn't credit
them or acknowledge it you just said no
this is mine like yeah that'd be a dick
move right there's nothing wrong with
using someone's style you just have to
be honest about it oh you took
inspiration from that person then don't
pretend that you invented it just give
that person credit who cares if you use
an AI it's no different than using
tracing paper right it's like so what
like give credit where credit's due if
you want it to be yours bring something
to the table that seriously make
something fun bring your own voice to it
everybody stands on the backs of giants
everybody's benefited from all the hard
work other people have done so we can't
act like now so I'm like oh you can't
use someone else's Styles like no you
can use your style but just say it's
their style it's what you create it's
what you say it's like yeah that makes
sense to me you know if the AI is
trained on billions of images I mean
we're trained on yeah millions of images
you know it's like hip-hop it's like
samples you know but there there is a
there is a line it's up to the audience
to be moral people and support people
that you know create and don't just
support people that rip people off you
know I mean you're in it right you're in
it so you've acted you've performed
you're saying something you're doing
something even like yeah you're good all
right Nico I'm pretty set at ease now I
think we have the Creative Energy now to
wrap this piece out and uh I can't wait
to show it to you
so we are using AI at every level of
this piece from AI generator Roto to AI
generated images all sorts of crazy
things but the main thing we're doing
with AI is we're using it as a tool
we're not using it to create this entire
piece it's not actually you know taking
away creativity it's actually enabling
it in particular this shot here where we
have our Peter Parker being sucked into
the spider-verse basically what I was
able to do was bring our PNG image
sequence into stable diffusion and run
every single individual frame through as
a different art style so it creates a
really cool effect another thing we're
doing to blend these two different
cinematic universes and art styles in a
cohesive way is basically taking parts
of the spider-verse that are really
iconic such as these Kirby dot elements
we actually start to see those really
cool graphic images from the
spider-verse appear in our real world
scene so once our Peter Parker is sucked
into the spider-verse we needed to kind
of take some iconic MCU shots and
reimagine them in that classic
spiderverse style we're basically taking
our foreground characters and making it
so that only every second frame of them
is animated it's something that the
spider-verse movie uses to sell that 2D
animated look despite it being CG
characters what I'm also doing is adding
in that little comic Splash we added
this big Kaboom element behind when the
little drone explodes another example of
how we're kind of pushing the graphic
style in this video to take some of that
spider-verse feeling is a shot like this
where we're really going over the top
with all the graphic elements we
basically took this Hulk from Ragnarok
ran it through stable diffusion to
generate our face here it just made this
such a you know graphic looking shot he
has the white outline around him he's
got we really actually we went in there
and rotoed specifically his teeth so
they really pop so you can see here as
we step through we're not just basically
you know taking the Hulk and throwing a
Snapchat face filter on him we're
actually taking these images breaking
them apart rebuilding them piecing
together different graphic elements and
ultimately adding on our own kind of
look and style to this thing that's
inspired by the incredible incredible
art that was done for the into the
spider-verse movie so we still have a
bunch of work to do on this project
before it comes out this weekend but
because we did all of this work on the
front end using all these AI tools we're
able to basically just be in this
sandbox where we can pull all these
different images that we've created
using Ai and create this really awesome
final collage of images
Ben and I have been cranking on these
spider-verse shots almost every shot of
this piece we've edited together is a
VFX shot we're essentially making an
animated short film and it hasn't just
been us Jordan has been working on some
sick renders and Peter is working on the
final shot of the piece so we're getting
really close to the finish line but I
realized it's not complete unless we
have as many Spider-Man as humanly
possible appear and for that we're gonna
have to do a deep dive on the most
obscure Spider-Man
so we are sitting down here for a very
important reason we are going to find
all of the spider we're gonna find all
of them and we're gonna figure out which
ones will appear into the spider-verse
now they're working on the sequel to
into the spider-verse Spider-Man 2099 is
in the trailer but we gotta get the
cream of the crop you got to get the
ones that that truly reward the Die Hard
70s Japanese spider mix
[Laughter]
so we got that guy of course I just
thought of one remember this game dude
when we were kids this was like Cutting
Edge Cutting Edge you're like this is
real yeah and the whole city is like a
cloud I have one that I'd like to submit
and it might be the greatest Spider-Man
of all time golden sponge cake
Spider-Man he can only shoot Hostess
snacks yes
yes it was supposed to be I guess like a
cross promotion but then it became Canon
who would win golden sponge cake
Spider-Man versus Superman you can only
shoot Twinkies yeah he's going in there
son do you have another like crazy one
like that oh maybe you're familiar I
think they call him spider monkey Marvel
honestly stable diffusion puts hands for
feet anyway so what if we grab a shot of
Caesar from Planet of the Apes we Evie
sent a Spider-Man costume onto Caesar
yeah and then you just have a little
tail come up it's pretty good he'll be
on the list yeah I think we got it guys
I'll edit the final sequence together
hopefully
will be able to fit them all into the
piece and fulfill the promise that
everybody's home
[Music]
all right everybody
I hit a button on my computer a week ago
and a video has popped out and Fender
and I did nothing
it's true that's not true we spent a lot
of time on this and we're really excited
about it because there's some cool new
tech in it but also there's a lot of
love for the original spider-verse film
and uh yeah I just want to hop into it
see what you guys think
[Music]
hey what is this place it's the Nexus of
the Multiverse kid now shut up because I
don't remember which potion to put in
this little cup oh yeah this is the one
after me
[Music]
wow
oh
are you okay
I think so are you from another
dimension
well
it's a long story but
I'll make it quick
all right let's do this one last time
my name's Peter Parker I was bitten by a
radioactive spider and for six years
I've been need one and only Spider-Man
well I was dead for five those years but
that's another story
I saved a bunch of people I fell in love
saved the city and then the world I even
joined a team you might have heard of
them
nah not them
there was Captain America also we had
Hulk Thor Black Widow Scarlet Witch
Doctor Strange black panther Ant-Man
Falcon the Winter Soldier vision and uh
oh that guy with the bow and arrow and
I'll never forget my mentor Mr Stark
what else oh there was this big purple
guy his chin kind of looked like
huh
[Music]
who are these guys
[Music]
oh here we go
not again
who are you guys anyway I gotta say you
look just like me say my name and I
magically appeared
who's next
I'm gonna put some dirt in your eye
is this still part of the experiments
beware my tasty Hostess snacks
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that might be like the best use of
stable diffusion up to this point on the
planet and taking that Meme and taking
it to the power of ten thousand they're
just like thousands of freaking
Spiderman special shout out to Peter
that's the best shot if you had to guess
how many different iterations of
Spider-Man you guys generated with AI
okay hundreds yeah same with Doctor
Strange Doctor Strange is a cowboy for a
couple frames yeah it's pretty awesome
and the twos they're on freaking Thanos
animating on the twos like you guys did
is such a great touch it just makes it
feel so much more like it's a part of
that Universe yeah like watching this
right now it's like I forget that this
is being AI like a lot of this stuff is
AI generated I just get lost in the
sauce of it it's just like you guys have
like seamlessly integrated the style of
a spider verse well we didn't expect
going into this was how stable diffusion
would be so useful just for generating
like still frames of backgrounds and
like of course like the Spiderman it's
easy to dismiss how much actual hard
work is here it's like there's some AI
stuff but like 80 of this is just grit
you guys just like knuckling down and
making it Fenner like you brought that
extra level of it having an artistic
appeal to this thing Man Spider Boys
it's worth noting too that I don't think
that we would have gotten such good AI
results here if we didn't already have
such a realistic Spider-Man costume that
that was the biggest thing
if you guys are interested in seeing how
we're gonna keep pushing this technology
here hit that subscribe button freaking
like the video I don't know ring the
bell what else do they do hit our P.O
box hey
foreign